[Music]
hello everyone welcome to this debate on
living dangerously
risk is at the center of current concern
and most agree that one preventable
death is one death too many but we have
been content to allow 17,000 flu deaths
a year in the UK that could be radically
reduced if vaccination was compulsory we
allow an estimated 3 million people to
die each year from alcohol that's 1 in
20 of all deaths when a global ban on
production will stop this slaughter are
humans incapable of weighing of risk
rationally our governments any better
should we seek to reduce all risks and
outlaw activity between dangerous or
should we accept that all actions carry
risk and it is up to each of us to
determine the level of risk we are
prepared to take our panelists for this
debate are Steven thinker Steven Pinker
is a Johnstone family professor in the
psychology department at Harvard he is a
cognitive psychologist and best-selling
science writer who first rose to
prominence with the theory of language
demonstrating how evolution explains our
species innate capacity for language
Shami Chakrabarti is a prominent member
of the British Labour Party barrister
and human rights activist and until
recently for Shadow Attorney General for
England and Wales she is well known as
the former director of Liberty the
organization promoting civil liberties
and human rights Nobel prize-winning
psychologist and economist Daniel
Kahneman is famous for challenging the
assumption of human rationality that
prevailed in modern economic theory he
is professor emeritus of psychology and
public affairs at Princeton University's
Woodrow Wilson School eugene higgins
professor of psychology emeritus at
princeton university and a fellow of the
Center for rationality at the Hebrew
University in Jerusalem he's a member of
the National Academy of Sciences and the
recipient of the Presidential Medal of
Freedom show me Stephen Daniel welcome
thank you very much for being on this
panel I'm going to start off the debate
with a question are humans incapable of
weighing up risk rationally so Stephen
can we start with you
it's a strange question humans compared
to who compared to God compared to some
advanced race of space aliens obviously
some humans must be capable of weighing
up risks or we have no benchmark that
would allow us to judge whether anyone
is being rational or irrational and
obviously when it comes to everyday
risks we're all capable of some rational
judgment because we the world is a
dangerous place and and most of us stay
alive the annual death rate from
accidents is less than 1/100 of 1% so
that means most of the time people
aren't driving into incoming traffic
people don't take a shortcut from the
top floor of a tall building by jumping
over the balcony they take stairs
they keep kids out of danger and and
contrary to the advice of a certain
world leader people don't drink bleach
to ward off infectious disease that's
the work of our fellow panelists Danny
Kahneman shows that we don't appreciate
much smaller risks that can only be
ascertained through large data sets that
give us our actuarial probabilities an
obvious example is that people are far
too afraid plane travel compared to
automobile travel because of the
availability of images and anecdotes of
plane disasters after 9/11 for example
that are publicly an extra 1,500 extra
deaths in the United States when people
stayed off planes which they
irrationally thought were dangerous and
drove instead which was far more
hazardous so really the question should
be reframed as went for the judgments of
some humans license restrictions on the
choices of other humans and this raises
some additional questions the issues
that we posed at the beginning were
couched in terms of the we but the
question is who is the we and practice
we're talking about government coercion
over individual choices so the question
is when are those license the answers
got to be sometimes but in generally
general not all actions have risks
because you can't just do one thing we
wanted perfect safety we would stay in
bed all day and
that isn't perfectly safe and there's no
there can't be a rational answer to what
is the correct level of risk among a set
of alternatives each one of which poses
some risk although there can be
irrational answers how to keep those
choices consistent and since there is no
no such thing as we they're only some
humans and Evos in government exerting
power over other humans the question is
how can we ensure that those wielding
power do so in in justifiable ways given
that they themselves are subject to the
same irrationality since everyone else
the obvious example being responses to
terrorism where in order to keep their
populations safe the leaders of our
governments started to catastrophic wars
set up a whole bureaucracy that with a
threat to civil liberties order for
homeland security to protect people
against their risk namely terrorism
which is a tiny fraction of the risks
that we incur from other sources finally
since these questions are being raised
during the covert pandemic it's
essential to make a key distinction that
we're not talking about risks that
individuals incur such as whether
someone who has cancer chooses to take
some elective but potentially dangerous
therapy because we're talking about
diseases that are infectious where your
actions are do not simply involve risk
that you assume yourself but risks that
you impose on other people and that
completely reframes the debate it's more
similar to do we allow someone to spray
machine-gun fire in a crowded place
their liberty is kind of beside the
point when it comes to the cost that
they're imposing on others and in most
of the debates that were having now that
is what is at issue not people's
willingness to incur whisks themselves
show me your take on that question so
you're picking up very much from from
where Stephen left gamblers trace it
actuaries counter to insurance brokers
to monetize it but but I generally form
my views on risk
from human rights perspective I attempt
to value all lives equally rather than
sum over others but that is complex in
practice and it requires the
consideration of civil and political
rights as well as social economic and
cultural ones now given as we've heard
that there's no such thing as a
risk-free life or society the balancing
of risks can't simply be done on the
basis of statistics or for example
numbers of deaths from a particular
activity or course of action there are
other perhaps less quantifiable risks
for example to an individual's life or
quality of life from for example banning
alcohol or mountaineering or or even
from using torture in the infamous
ticking bomb scenario conversely to
completely ignore the good of the many
and just always make individual
judgments would effectively mean the end
of society and it would be intolerably
unjust to the vulnerable and not least
again as Steven said in the case of the
spread of a deadly and highly infectious
pandemic so a human rights approach
identifies which individual rights are
absolutes and which are little more
qualified in and in the case of that
latter
and larger group of liberties
interferences with the individual
freedom may be justified for the
protection of others when proportionate
and crucially when applied in a
non-discriminatory manner now leaving
people to take certain risks with their
own light is a good liberal principle
for any democratic society but not when
they are also risking the lives of
others hence we don't ban alcohol but we
regulate its strength and its sale and
we forgive people driving under its
influence that's why I think some of the
more libertarian complains about the
covert 19 lock down have seemed so
selfish and out of kilter with a lot of
the general public mood if not all of it
Thank You Daniel your take this subject
is very much any or we love well
the question are humans incapable of
weighing risk rationally is ambiguous
does it refer to individual humans or
with humanity in other interpretation
the short answer to the question is no
individuals and societies are certainly
capable of rational reasonable action I
prefer to avoid the term rationality
because it's a technical term and
certainly people are not able to attack
Russian but they are capable of acting
reasonably now I prefer to focus on
societies and the ability of societies
throughout rationally society that are
guided by good science can deal
appropriately with threats that are
familiar and immediate like hurricanes
however some threats Pro the challenge
to the human mind and there are two that
are highly prominent these days threats
that draw experiencing me and with the
lab are completely incomprehensible so
27 percent increase the daily increase
in the rate of a pandemic means doubling
every three days and it means that if 30
days
it grows by a factor of 1,000 the human
mind is completely incapable of dealing
with it with exponential growth so
threats of that kind risks of that kind
will we'll need some other treatment
than human intuition of human unaided
reason to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you